[Musique]
l'excellence française dans la mode
remonte sans doute au 17e siècle à
l'époque de Louis XIV c'est au 19e que
naît le défilé la notion de collection
avec Frédéric worse il faudra attendre
les années
1880 pour que le terme haute couture
soit définitivement établie alors
aujourd'hui nous avons beaucoup de
chance nous sommes dans l'appartement
d'une légende de la haute couture
parisienne celui de Gabriel Chanel elle
va créer sa maison en 1909 mais va
s'installer ici rue Cambon à Paris à
partir de 1910
c'est ici qu'elle recevait ses plus
proches collaborateurs c'est mannequins
mais aussi et surtout ces artisans d'art
qui travaillaient pour et avec elle nous
allons maintenant partir à la rencontre
de ces hommes et de ses femmes qui
donnent vie à ses collections c'est
véritables trésors de la haute couture
française pour vous nous avons poussé
les portes des plus grandes maisons
Chanel bien sûr mais aussi Christian
Dior ce qui apparait lit Yves Saint
Laurent entre autres
c'est dans les ateliers de ces maisons
que nous avons rencontré les virtuoses
de la haute couture le temps d'une
collection nous avons vécu avec les
brodeurs plus massiers bottier plisseur
les plus expérimentés tous passionnés
qui nous ont fait partager leur
savoir-faire je pense que quelqu'un qui
regarde de près la broderie ressens
cette émotion
la broderie c'est de l'émotion ouais
sécher le brodeur le sage que les
petites mains s'activent sur une pièce
unique qui a nécessité plus de 800
heures de travail
chez le plus Massier le marié les
artisans créent sous nos yeux une robe
au 12500 plumes cousues une à une à la
main
pendant que dans les ateliers de couture
Chanel les premières nous livrent leurs
secrets de fabrication nous avons aussi
suivi les stylistes dans leur démarche
créatrice ils puisent leur inspiration
dans un patrimoine unique
toujours le même plaisir
ça c'est superbe
[Musique]
ça doit être la collection cirque non
nous sommes allés à la recherche des
pièces les plus audacieuses et
novatrices des plus grandes maisons les
broderies en béton de Chanel ou la robe
en porcelaine de ce qui apparaît lit
enfin les maisons Yves Saint Laurent et
Christian Dior nous ont ouvert leurs
réserves pour découvrir les pièces
mythiques qui ont fait la réputation de
ces grands couturiers et pour la
première fois la maison Chanel a
autorisé une caméra à filmer dans son
sanctuaire incroyable quelques-uns de
ces 6000 trésors des trésors qui depuis
plus d'un siècle font de Paris et de la
France le centre du monde quelque part
on est quand même des créateurs de rêves
parce qu'il y a des gens qui arrivent
avec des projets fous et on arrive à
donner satisfaction
[Musique]
juillet 2016 la collection haute couture
automne-hiver investit la capitale de la
mode
pendant une semaine Paris accueille une
trentaine de défilés
[Musique]
sur les podiums détenus d'exception
imaginées par des créateurs mais brodés
plissés coupés par des artisans
d'excellence qui travaille dans l'ombre
des grandes maisons
ce jour-là un grand styliste Karl
Lagerfeld rent un hommage appuyé à ses
petites mains des métiers d'art à
travers le décor du défilé transformé en
atelier mais aussi à travers les quatre
premières qui dirigent les couturières
de la maison Chanel c'est avec elle
qu'il a choisi cette fois-ci de partager
les applaudissements du public
j'avais envie que les premières et les
ouvrières voient leurs collection du
filet et en plus comme c'était très près
du public je trouvais ça donne une
osmose assez intéressante non
c'est amusant que les gens voient comme
les grands luxe fabriquent que c'est
fait comme il y a 100 ans
et parmi les quatre premières mises en
avant Cécile 15 ans de maison 40 ans de
métiers que cet hommage à bouleversé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai du mal à formuler l'émotion que je
ressens parce que c'est un métier qui
est dur d'être passionné il faut être
patient pour le faire ou une
persévérance de tous les jours c'est
mettre en avant toutes ces filles qui
sont sur le tabouret tout le temps les
plus Massir les brodeuses tout le monde
tout le monde au travers au travers de
nous les premiers tournent en avant et
ça c'est il y a pas de mots j'ai pas
j'ai pas de mots mettre en avant tous
ces métiers d'art c'est reconnaître que
son oeufs la haute couture n'aurait pas
existé une évidence pour Bruno pavlowski
président des activités mode de Chanel
disons cette capacité à proposer à
rebondir
à interpréter les demandes qui sont
faites
quelquefois quand même des niches assez
spécifique c'est c'est une petite partie
2 mais cette petite partie ajoutée à une
autre petite partie font que l'objet la
robe devient tout à fait magique donc
oui aujourd'hui il n'existe
sans ces métiers d'art la haute couture
ne pouvait pas être scannée
et notamment sans la broderie la maison
Dios s'adresse à l'atelier Vermont situé
dans le vieux Paris Faubourg
Poissonnière
six jours plus tôt tout l'atelier
s'activait encore sur les broderies
d'une basque pour un tailleur pantalon
de la collection automne-hiver de la
maison Dior
on doit rendre pratiquement tout
aujourd'hui demain et après-demain pour
chaque broderie commandée tout commence
par un échantillon élaboré par les
brodeuses de la maison Vermont selon les
demandes et les exigences de la maison
de couture
à la base l'échantillon esthéticienne
fille le craie sous une directive
évidemment de la maison Dior il nous
donne les couleurs de l'or de l'argent
après je choisis c'est et là il a été
validé
[Musique]
pour le reproduire l'échantillon est
dessiné minutieusement légendées et
reporté sur un calque piqué à la main
avec dextérité par les dessinatrices
donc je suis vraiment ma légende pour
pas qu'il y ait de confusion après au
niveau de la broderie
chaque type de perles et soigneusement
noté et codifiés là ici nous avons
travaillé des tubes en orgue de
différentes couleurs
qui se retrouvent ici ça c'est l'axe de
pose des tubes et là ça va être la
couleur la croix représente le noir le
petit trait représente l'argent et le
point représente l'or comme ça la
brodeuse elle sera exactement quoi
mettre et dans quel sens le mettre
[Musique]
double toujours les calques on garde le
dessiner tel que pour pouvoir faire les
jambes après et on prend celui qu'on a
piqué donc il y a pas le dessin il y a
que le dessin qui est piqué
donc là je viens passer la poudre
et là je viens à
[Musique]
je viens sécher voir fixer
une étape préparatoire essentielle pour
que les brodeuses puissent travailler
je t'apporte un autre morceau de la
basque avec son dessin légendé et
l'échantillon voilà depuis des siècles
les gestes sont les mêmes les techniques
se perpétuent de génération en
génération c'est la technique du crochet
de Lunéville c'est une technique qui a
été mis au point à Lunéville il y a
plusieurs centaines d'années maintenant
mais donc c'est un savoir-faire que
qu'on a gardé et qu'on utilise encore
aujourd'hui donc c'est pour poser en
fait tout ce qui est fourniture donc
perles ou paillettes la particularité de
cette technique c'est qu'on va poser
toutes les fournitures en fait à
l'envers
en dessous avec son doigt la matière ça
peut être une paillette une perle ou un
tube et une à une elle est posée et
maintenue par une chaînée Mathilde vous
en est où
[Musique]
est-ce que la base qui est du coup toute
terminée les morceaux
et après j'ai la veste
présenté ce cet échantillon qui est fait
de l'âme vous voyez c'est de la lame
argent et de la lame or des perles des
petites fleurs donc la lame se présente
vous le voyez sur les métiers sur le
métier d'Alisa
voilà la lame c'est du métal
ce sont des rubans de métal qu'on va
poser là vous voyez on a fait un petit
bourrage et après on lance ce que fait
Tommy
on lance de la lame pour recouvrir le
bourrage et faire une forme de grappe
vous voyez que c'est l'intervention de
la machine n'existe pas c'est tout
on Brotte comme on pourrait broder il y
a 100 150 ans c'est toujours pareil
c'est brodeuses sont les héritières de
savoir-faire d'excellence à la française
liée à notre histoire
ils ont été codifiés pour certains au
13ème siècle et puis c'est Louis XIV qui
a installé vraiment tous les métiers
d'art au service de la gloire de l'État
l'art et la mode au service de l'État il
a fait venir des artisans de l'Europe
entière les plus spécialisés dans chaque
domaine du luxe il a installé avec
Colbert des manufactures et à partir de
là ça a été un art total qui a rayonné
partout partout en Europe et même dans
le monde bien au-delà de l'Europe un
héritage unique que l'on sauvegarde
depuis longtemps comme ici dans la
maison Lesage l'atelier de broderie le
plus prestigieux créé en 1924
Muriel Lemoine et la directrice du
patrimoine Lesage aujourd'hui elle
reçoit Bertrand Guyon le styliste haute
couture de la marque skiaparelli pour
une séance de travail dans ces boîtes
75000 échantillons créés par l'atelier
le sage pour les plus grands couturiers
de Chanel à Yves Saint Laurent un siècle
de haute couture
ça c'est superbe
ça doit être la collection cirque non je
pense oui je pense ici dans toutes ces
boîtes vous avez toutes l'évolution de
l'histoire de la mode de la fin du 19e
jusqu'à nos jours c'est inouï c'est
unique d'ailleurs je crois qu'il
n'existe aucune maison à avoir une
archive aussi importante un trésor
inestimable pour les stylistes
d'aujourd'hui qui viennent épuiser leur
inspiration c'est vraiment parti
intégrante du patrimoine français et
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut préserver
à tout prix c'est une richesse que nous
en vit le monde entier
pour sa prochaine collection Bertrand
Guyon vient s'imprégner des échantillons
d'Alsace qui apparait lit l'une des
grandes créatrices de l'antre de guerre
dont il représente aujourd'hui la maison
ce qui m'intéresse c'est d'essayer de
comprendre
le travail d'Alsace qui apparaîti et de
le
d'essayer de le traduire sans la
trahir le reproduire à l'identique ça
n'aurait pas beaucoup d'intérêt en
revanche ce qui est intéressant c'est
retraduire les chevaux
de manège
en le traitant avec des des sensibilités
d'aujourd'hui des matières et un goût
d'aujourd'hui c'est joli ça ouais un
petit peu abîmé mais c'est trésors
témoigne tout aussi de l'extraordinaire
inventivité des stylistes et notamment
d'Elsa qui apparaît lit la première à
avoir introduit en Haute Couture le rose
shocking et les couleurs vives
vous avez une association un mélange des
couleurs que l'on ne retrouve pas
forcément à cette époque et
la maison le sage a su avec elle bien
évidemment travailler sur des
associations des mélanges en fait vous
avez des du turquoise du show King les
mélanges de lames très utilisées à cette
période
des strass mais pas trop et chaque
échantillon même le plus petit que vous
trouvez dans dans nos boîtes et bien est
complètement mais magique en couleur et
on imagine aujourd'hui en 2016 tout à
fait porter et on a vraiment ce
sentiment que que l'échantillon a été
créé aujourd'hui et ça ça c'est assez
exceptionnel
Alsace qui apparaît lit a ouvert sa
maison de couture à Paris Place Vendôme
en 1927 cet aristocrate italienne grande
rivale de Gabriel Chanel a révolutionné
la haute couture de l'entre-deux-guerres
[Musique]
travailler avec une manière très
particulière puisque elle va introduire
l'art dans la mode en travaillant avec
des artistes notamment avec Dali et avec
sa femme Gala elle va faire des choses à
ses extravagantes elle va travailler par
thème et ça c'est un point important
parce que c'est la première qui va
mettre au point des thèmes comme le
cirque le cosmos la musique etc et elle
va donner à tous ces fournisseurs ce
thème sur lequel ils vont broder
le musée Galliera à Paris conserve
quelques-uns des vêtements emblématiques
de la styliste
c'est dans ses réserves que se trouve la
célèbre cap Fébus le nom du dieu soleil
dans la Grèce antique elle a été
réalisée par la maison le sage pour la
collection Cosmos de 1938
[Musique]
ce qui est particulièrement frappant
dans cette cape c'est évidemment le dos
qui donne donc son nom au modèle la cape
Fébus avec ce soleil rayonnant
particulièrement remarquable
cette cape est emblématique par sa
couleur rose choquine qui est tellement
tellement qui résume presque à lui seul
ce qu'est Alsace qui apparaît
il y a quelque chose qui faut également
voir mais qui ne se découvre que quand
on retourne la pièce
[Musique]
c'est le travail de la doublure qui
manifeste un très très grand raffinement
vous voyez qu'il y a un travail qui
donne l'illusion d'une sorte de capiton
avec des boutons en fil métallique donc
passementerie
doré sur ce fond rose shocking et il est
certain que là si on parle de cet
exemple précis la collaboration avec le
sage et particulièrement remarquable
chez le sage l'échantillon est encadré
tel un trésor symbole de l'âge d'or de
la maison une période particulièrement
novatrice ou madame Lesage avait poussé
à l'extrême l'excellence de son
savoir-faire c'est elle qui a inventé
dans les années 30 un point mythique le
vermicelle carré une merveille de
technique et d'esthétique
le vernis selle carré vous avez une
toute petite perle maintenue mes micros
presque microscopiques maintenu par un
petit fil et en fait la technique est
c'est-à-dire au carré c'est à dire qu'on
fait un premier point pour maintenir un
deuxième et un troisième et en fait vous
faites un carré et vous et vous tournez
pas en rond en fait vous tournez
pratiquement avec un petit carré et en
fait on a l'impression même que ça nous
tient à rien mais vous avez une toute
petite chaînette qui est à l'arrière et
qui pratiquement microscopique
les dessins sont juste extraordinaire et
d'une légèreté
très moderne exactement
c'est magnifique ce savoir-faire
précieux est encore transmis aujourd'hui
dans les ateliers Lesage
rachetés par la maison Chanel en 2002
les ateliers le sage continuent à
travailler pour de nombreux stylistes de
haute couture
sur ces grandes tables une longue robe
de mousseline peinte pour la maison
Valentino autour de laquelle s'affaire
pas moins d'une dizaine de brodeuses à
quelques jours des défilés les broderies
sont presque terminées
on a les paillettes donc elles sont
plates on a la chenille on a du ruban
aussi pour poser le ruban c'est vraiment
une technique bien particulière il est
maintenu de chaque côté avec un petit
point donc la difficulté c'est de
pouvoir le tourner on le tourne dans un
sens dans un autre pour suivre la forme
et puis lui donner et lui donner un du
relief
la difficulté c'est que déjà le tissu
c'est un tissu qui est quand même très
fragile donc il faut l'attention soit
pas trop forte il faut faire attention
de ne pas érailler le tissu ou de tirer
les fils après on est plusieurs à
travailler dessus donc déjà faut qu'on
travaille à peu près toutes pareil
près de 800 heures passées déjà sur
cette broderie et pourtant la robe
semble encore inachevée une demande
spécifique de Maria Gracia alors
styliste chez Valentino
le couturiers a choisi une vieille
archive qu'il avait et donc comme elle
est très ancienne donc il y a des
parties qui sont déchirées il y a des
parties où là où la broderie elle est un
petit peu partie donc ça fait comme si
ça faisait des vides donc on a voulu
reproduire la même chose avec la
nouvelle Rome et donc dans ces parties
ici là que l'on voit ici donc nous on a
juste fait pour l'instant le contour
mais ensuite ça va être déchiré à
l'intérieur pour donner justement aussi
cet effet usé
et voici la robe 5 jours plus tard au
défilé Valentino reproduire cet effet
nostalgique d'une robe surannée
usée par le ton déchiré seul la haute
couture peut se le permettre Marie des
galons de la robe scar21 je sais plus
quoi ils sont prêts c'est fini retour
chez le sage Hubert Barrère est
responsable des nombreuses broderies
réalisées pour chaque collection de la
maison Chanel
elle va être super contente madame
Josette là haut de couture c'est comme
une sorte de laboratoire d'hier
donc on va le plus loin possible dans la
création et dans la technique
heureusement d'ailleurs
[Musique]
métier d'art et haute couture sont
intimement liées difficiles de faire
perdurer l'un sans l'autre
monsieur le sage disait que un défilé de
l'autre couture sans broderie ce serait
comme un 14 juillet qui n'aurait pas de
feu d'artifice mais sans la haute
couture la broderie ne pourrait pas
avoir ses lettres de noblesse en
revanche ce serait beaucoup moins facile
et légitime de
faire perdurer le savoir-faire de la de
la broderie je pense
oui devenir une brodeuse d'exception
dans cet atelier prestigieux c'était le
rêve de Caroline brodeuse chez le sage
depuis quatre ans une reconversion
réussie j'étais responsable de secteur
pour une marque de cosmétique et au bout
d'un moment j'étais un petit peu
fatiguée des tableaux de chiffres et des
résultats de vente j'avais envie de
travailler avec mes mains puis surtout
j'avais envie de construire quelque
chose avec mes mains
ce sont des galons qui vont aller sur
une veste qu'on a déjà brodé et déjà
envoyé chez Chanel
donc là en fait ce sont des galons qu'on
va rajouter sur les emmanchures et au
niveau du col
sur ce galon on travaille exclusivement
à l'aiguille
on a d'abord en fait utiliser deux
mèches de laine de 13 brins chacun qu'on
a entrelacé et fixé avec des fleursettes
et des toupies et ensuite par dessus on
vient rajouter ici les ponts de perles
faire l'habillage
et voyez là je me suis trompé je l'ai
fait dans le mauvais sens donc je
recommence
la bourdine n'est pas un métier c'est
une passion il y a un supplément d'
Alpes qui est absolument obligatoire
parce que la broderie c'est pas juste
trois perles qui sont posées comme ça
c'est une broderie qui est faite avec le
cœur et la main
et je pense que quelqu'un qui regarde de
près la broderie ressent cette émotion
la broderie c'est de l'émotion ouais
et pendant que les brodeurs travaillent
d'arrache-pied dans les ateliers de
couture des grandes maisons les
couturières s'activent elles aussi et
coupe l'étoile de tous les modèles
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour rue Cambon mais
cette fois dans les ateliers de la
maison Chanel et c'est vraiment un
privilège d'être ici et de vous
rencontrer ma chère Olivia comment
dois-je vous appeler Madame Olivia
mademoiselle Olivia ou Olivier tout
court si c'est moi choisir je préfère
mademoiselle Olivia mais dans la haute
couture on dit Madame Olivia c'est une
tradition c'est une tradition il y a
combien d'ateliers exactement dans la
maison Chanel nous avons quatre ateliers
haute couture donc deux ateliers
tailleurs et deux ateliers flous alors
combien d'étapes sont nécessaires entre
le moment où Karl Lagerfeld vous donne
son croquis la réalisation de de la robe
j'allais dire de l'oeuvre terminée alors
déjà il y a les réalisations du
patronage donc je prends le croquis de
Carl je l'analyse je regarde comment il
est comment il est fait les lignes les
courbes je me plonge aussi dans le thème
pour pour sentir aussi le vêtement et
suite à ça donc un premier essayage en
toile c'est ce qu'on a là derrière nous
c'est ça voilà tout à fait donc ça c'est
la robe que nous avons préparée pour le
premier essayage on sait
c'est du factice on a on a fait tout en
toile et c'est du dessin suite au
premier essayage nous lançons les vrais
broderies et nous lançons dans le vrai
tissu qui a été choisi au moment de
l'essayage d'accord alors là par exemple
on a une toile comme vous dites et la
robe définitive juste à côté tout à fait
vous avez l'exemple type de la toile et
le modèle fini et vous travaillez
vraiment en étroite collaboration avec
tous les artisans on voit des choses
absolument exceptionnelles à côté de
vous donc c'est un travail très fin très
joli qu'est-ce qu'elle est belle cette
broderie c'est absolument magnifique
j'imagine qu'il faut des centaines
d'heures de travail des centaines et des
centaines d'heures
j'imagine et puis il doit y avoir une
grande confidentialité entre le brodeur
et le style jusqu'au bout du défilé mais
toute façon les brodeurs ont l'habitude
de ça on travaille vraiment comme ça
jusqu'au bout une grande confidentialité
une grande complicité entre le styliste
et le brodeur comme on va le voir
[Musique]
c'est très joli c'est très très joli
mais muriel est pas là faudrait charger
un peu plus
[Musique]
tu me connais en fait ouais ouais non
non c'est très très beau je pense que ça
va être super joli avec la lumière ça va
être très très beau le jeune styliste
Alexandre Vautier est venu suivre et
corriger sur place chez le sage la
broderie d'un de ces modèles farde de sa
collection c'est Muriel Lemoine qui est
la coordinatrice entre le styliste et
l'atelier
se situe enfonces ton noir faudrait
renforcer un poil le verre et donc du
coup renforcer comme le noir et plein là
un soupçon et comme le noir là est
vraiment presque en foule faut rajouter
du de l'olivine en fait cette broderie
c'est en fait
comment rehausser un
imprimé qui est qui est universel et qui
existe depuis des années et des années
des années et le transposer dans le dans
un côté excessivement luxe moi ce que
j'adore c'est ça tu vois cette partie là
quand ça devient un peu mélangé et
poussiéreux tu vois comme ça anecdotique
tu vois tu perds de ta force en verre et
tout ça
Alexandre Vautier travaill exclusivement
avec Jean-Marie le seul homme Brodeur
chez Lesage
Jean-Marie je le connais depuis on va
dire quelques années
voilà fallait pas le dire mais bon vingt
ans on a un vocabulaire en commun qui
fait que lorsque je commence à
travailler mes broderies sur sur la
couture il est toujours là parce qu'il
comprend et Muriel aussi parce que ça
fait 20 ans que je la connais aussi ils
comprennent très vite ce que je veux et
j'ai une espèce de complicité
professionnelle qui se fait et
on essaye chaque saison de faire des
choses un peu différentes de se
renouveler et trouver des nouvelles
technicité de nouveaux mélanges pour
justement être assez surprenante par le
biais de ces métiers d'art
Muriel as-tu me livre demain
[Rires]
quelques fois cette complicité devient
si intime que l'artisanat est capable
d'interpréter à la perfection l'idée du
styliste une symbiose qui est souvent à
l'origine de nombreux chefs
et Yves Saint Laurent cet échantillon
que je vais vous montrer nous a tenu
pendant des heures puisque je pense de
mémoire que la veste je pense qu'il y
avait 1000 heures de travail et tout le
monde a travaillé toutes les brodes
toute la maison travailler sur les
raisins que vous avez ici ce sont des
toutes petites boules avec des je pense
qu'il y a 50 coloris de fournitures
différentes et cette collaboration avec
Monsieur Saint-Laurent en fait c'est
parti de rien en fait juste d'un mot ce
mot Bonnard le peintre
cet échantillon appartient à la
collection hommage au grand peintre elle
est aujourd'hui précieusement conservée
dans les réserves de la Fondation Yves
Saint Laurent à Paris que nous ouvre sa
responsable Sandrine teinturier
dans ces armoires plus de 5000 vêtements
d'exception 40 ans de haute couture de
la maison Yves Saint Laurent dont cette
fameuse collection de 1988
si nous avons deux pièces remarquables
qui sont deux hommages à Van Gogh
qui reprennent les
tableaux des iris et des et des
tournesols et qui ont été réalisés par
le sage
ces pièces remarquables parce que elles
ont nécessité chacune autour de 700
heures de broderie avec une technique
qui est assez propre à le sage qui
utilise des matériaux assez assez
communs pour les brodeurs des paillettes
des parcs de rocaille mais qui en plus a
inclus comme vous le voyez des des
rubans et avec des effets de maths
brillants qui qui donne l'effet de coups
de pinceau qui
qui ressemble vraiment à de la peinture
il y a une autre veste exceptionnelle
qui fait partie de la collection hommage
et qui est un hommage d'Yves Saint
Laurent à la maison de couture et il a
demandé à le sage comme on aurait
demandé une robe couleur de temps de
réfléchir à une broderie qui arriverait
à traduire la lumière qui passe à
travers le lustre des grands salons des
salons de couture
Yves Saint Laurent styliste surdoué et
visionnaire se retrouve à la tête de la
maison Dior à seulement 21 ans quatre
ans plus tard il n'a que 25 ans quand il
crée en 1961 avec Pierre Berger sa
propre maison de couture très vite il
bouleverse les codes de la mode et ceux
de la société il a donné le pouvoir aux
femmes au travers d'une garde-robe qui
était un transfuge de la garde-robe
masculine alors vous avez le tailleur
pantalon bien évidemment le smoking bien
sûr mais aussi là ça arienne le jumpsuit
le caban la marinière il a pris
pratiquement tous les éléments du
vestiaire masculin et il a donné aux
femmes le pouvoir de les porter il a
fait rentrer le pantalon dans les
bureaux finalement
lorsque dans les années 70 les riches
clientes délaissent les maisons de haute
couture pour le prêt-à-porter de luxe
les métiers d'art et la transmission de
leur savoir-faire sont alors en danger
jusqu'à ce que Yves Saint Laurent en
1976 relance les industries du luxe en
général c'est à dire tous les métiers
d'art et la haute couture en particulier
avec une collection qui s'appelle Opera
ballerus qui est d'une opulence
extraordinaire qui emploie des tissus du
brocard des tissus d'or de la soie
nouveau à profusion des fourrures des
broderies et ça relance tout à coup
l'intérêt pour cette profession ça
montre que elle peut être d'avant-garde
ça montre qu'elle peut être à la pointe
du désir et qu'elle peut relancer le
désir des femmes
dès lors Yves Saint Laurent s'entoure
des plus grands artisans d'art parisien
et avant de quitter le monde de la haute
couture en 2002 créé avec eux des pièces
extraordinaires
il s'agit du manteau Lyon qui a manteau
de l'hiver
90 c'est des plumes de faisan des plumes
de vautours
[Musique]
la demande d'Yves Saint Laurent adressée
à le marier était je voudrais un manteau
de plumes qui ressemble à un lion
3000 plumes teintes et cousues une à une
à la main sur un organe très léger une
pièce exceptionnelle
parce qu'elle est elle est spectaculaire
et seulement tout qu'on aime beaucoup
qui est très très fragile donc assez peu
exposé les bêtes adorent les plumes donc
c'est quelque chose qu'on surveille
particulièrement on a dans nos réserves
les plumes sont dans un endroit
particulier qu'on surveille plus que les
autres choses ce manteau a été réalisé
par la maison Lemarié le plus grand plus
Massié au monde incontournable pour la
haute couture depuis le 19e siècle la
maison nous a ouvert ses coulisses
donc là on va rentrer dans la réserve de
plumes si vous voulez bien hein
vous voyez toutes les plumes sont
répertoriées toutes rangés dans des
boîtes identifiées et là par exemple
nous avons mis de côté toutes les plumes
que nous venons de teindre et que nous
allons utiliser pour le modèle de la
haute couture un tailleur Chanel de la
nouvelle collection automne-hiver que la
maison Lemarié est en train de réaliser
alors elles sont en sachet on a un
camaïeu de couleur qui sont représentés
vous voyez elles sont donc
vous avez
tout le toutes les couleurs utilisées
dans le sur le modèle
alors en plus ou moins grande quantité
suivant le dosage que l'on veut donner
et là en fait elles sont naturelles donc
en fait c'est plus là qui ont été
teintes et utilisées c'est de loi la
nageoire une plus élégante et souple qui
se trouve sur les flancs de l'animal
c'est une plume qui qui se teint bien
qui et qui se prêtait bien à cette fleur
on n'allait pas utiliser de l'autruche
voyez pour faire un aplat de plumes
comme ça les plumes d'autruche la maison
les destine plutôt à l'une des pièces
emblématiques de la prochaine collection
haute couture Chanel la robe de mariée
un travail sur un grand col où on vient
mélanger en fait de l'autruche du brin
d'autruche brûlé et des fouets de coq là
c'est le brun entier et là c'est le brin
qui a été travaillé en fait
je vais vous montrer aussi le fouet de
coq poudré donc dans les mêmes tons qui
est très aérien très joli et qui donne
parsemé dans le les brins d'autruche va
donner un petit supplément dans la le
modèle voilà bien sûr nous avons des
plumes nous regrettons pas pouvoir
utiliser les les graisses l'oiseau de
paradis qui sont des plumes tout
simplement magnifiques les graisses on
en trouve plus ça c'est un stock très
précieux que nous avons parce que c'est
un animal complètement protégé on peut
pas en acheter on peut pas en vendre
mais bon quand vous avez vous voyez
c'est tout simplement
magnifique
on a aussi les oiseaux de paradis qu'on
conserve dans une très très vieille
boîte mais quand vous voyez le dégradé
de couleur et la légèreté de ses plumes
avec ces beiges marrons
ce jaune tellement délicat très très
pâle je ne pense pas même avec les
meilleures teinturiers qu'on pourrait
arriver à cette subtilité de ton ça fait
partie du patrimoine de la maison et on
les conserve et on prend énormément soin
d'elle un stock précieux à qui avant les
mesures prises pour sauvegarder ses
oiseaux
à l'étage au-dessus dont les ateliers
les plus massièrent travaillent pour
toutes les maisons d'hôtes couture qui
réclament leur savoir-faire unique ce
jour-là elle s'active autour d'un
tailleur Chanel nous y retrouvons les
nageoires utilisées en aplat une
technique mise au point ici
[Musique]
le vrai plus de la maison le marié c'est
qu'ici toutes les personnes qui
travaillent dans cet atelier travaillent
toutes les techniques donc on peut faire
un travail de plume classique de pincer
d'autruche fixées sur une base mais on
peut aussi faire ce qu'on appelle nous
une marqueterie de plumes c'est à dire
que là ce n'est pas de la broderie c'est
pas du fil c'est des plumes qui sont
découpées morceaux par morceaux plumes
par plume pour reconstituer un dessin
donc là on a un travail uniquement de
plus généralement le duvet ici on
l'enlève on l'utilise jamais et après on
va utiliser les barbes vous avez la côte
centrale l'arête ensuite vous avez les
barbes qui qui partent de chaque côté
donc là pour la marqueterie j'ai encollé
ma partie et après
je récupère mes barbes
et après je vais le découper à la forme
que je veux donc là on l'utilise pas en
tant que plume pour sa forme mais pour
sa matière
la plume aussi il y a une vraie
brillance suivant la manière dont on la
regarde ça prend la lumière de manière
très différente sache à toi ça intrigue
et à peut-être ce côté intrigant qui est
un petit peu différent et puis nous là
de sûretéchantillon bien on l'a encore
plus éclairé avec certains strass
certaines perles qui viennent apporter
un peu plus de brillance encore modèle
et puis il y a un volume le volume est
donné par les plumes je pense
4 jours plus tard le modèle était
terminé et défilé avec toute la
collection
le savoir-faire des ateliers parisiens
c'est aussi savoir respecter des délais
très courts
un peu à l'écart nous retrouvons les
plus grosses poudrés destinés au col de
la robe de mariée sur lequel Valentin
fraîchement devenu plus Massié travail
depuis cinq jours cet élément va venir
recouvrir la Manche plus la partie
encolure et l'autre manche pour éviter
d'avoir un
raccord on l'a fait en une fois pour
quelque chose d'un peu plus uniforme
[Musique]
ce col doit être livré le soir même il a
nécessité plus de 2500 plumes et plus de
100 heures de travail la technique est
classique il s'agit de pincer les plumes
et de les fixer sur une base de tulle et
de dentelle sur un petit laiton
qui devient impliqué et ensuite tous ces
piquets donc ici on a à peu près 300 je
crois
on vient les assembler ce qui permet
d'avoir l'élément entier
donc là c'est en cours d'assemblage
plus d'un siècle que la maison Chanel
collabore étroitement avec ce plus acier
de légende à tel point qu'en 1996 pour
sauvegarder ce trésor de savoir-faire et
ce patrimoine les ateliers le mariés ont
été rachetés par la maison de haute
couture la plus ancienne et la plus
mythique au monde
aujourd'hui c'est dans cet écrin
high-tech que la maison Chanel conserve
son patrimoine
c'est la première fois que la maison
ouvra une caméra les portes de son
sanctuaire où tous les modèles de
Mademoiselle Chanel sont sauvegardés un
trésor inestimable
j'ai imaginé
un tout comme vous pouvez remarquer les
modèles les plus fragiles sont
conservés à plat ce sont tous les
modèles qui ne supportent pas la
suspension
donc on les préserve de cette façon à
plat
on a environ
6000 modèles quand je dis modèle ce sont
des modèles complets donc en termes de
pièces ça fait évidemment beaucoup plus
mais on a à peu près oui entre 6000 6500
looks à peu près je compte à la fois
Gabriel Chanel et Karl Lagerfeld bien
sûr on a énormément de trésors on a même
un tailleur qui est appartenu à Gabriel
Chanel d'ailleurs là voilà ça semble une
toute petite chose comme ça là on est
dans la relique en Espagne
Chanel a apporté énormément à la mode
d'abord elle a été une égérie elle a été
une femme libre donc elle s'est
comportée comme une femme libre sa
liberté elle la doit son travail et elle
s'est portée comme modèle pour les
autres femmes
ça mode est exemple de préjugés elle va
apporter la première des pyjamas de
plage
des pantalons c'est extrêmement novateur
Gabriel Chanel est issu d'un milieu des
plus modestes elle a une formation de
couturière et à 26 ans en 1909 simple
modiste elle arrive à Paris pour créer
des chapeaux qui plaisent à la bonne
société
un an plus tard et des financièrement
par un riche amant elle installe son
atelier puis son appartement rue Cambon
pour créer des vêtements
on a installé ici une petite blouse qui
n'a l'air de rien mais c'est notre
Joconde c'est une blouse qui a 100 ans
elle date de 1916 et c'est la pièce la
plus ancienne connue de Gabriel Chanel à
ce jour elle présente évidemment la
particularité d'être en jersey se jersey
de soie qu'elle a emprunté à la
garde-robe masculine le jersey
auparavant on en faisait des
sous-vêtements et Chanel s'est permis à
oser le volet aux hommes le détourner
pour en faire des blouses confortables
pour elle et pour ses clientes les
vêtements de Jersey ont existé déjà pour
les femmes ils étaient spécifiques pour
le sport et il y en avait plein les
rayons des grands magasins c'était des
vêtements qui permettait la plus grande
mobilité sachanale n'avait parfaitement
compris et elle va utiliser cette
matière là elle va s'inspirer du style
marin qui est celui des pêcheurs de la
côte normande
elle va faire un mix de ça et elle va
être en plein dans le mille puisque les
femmes à ce moment-là ont besoin de
vêtements qui ont en raccourci qui
seront un peu éloignés du corps qui sont
souples qui auront des poches qui auront
des boutons ça c'est une nouveauté aussi
dans le vestiaire féminin et elle va
obtenir un immense succès avec ça il va
être la première si vous voulez à
formaliser ce vêtement le griffer à lui
donner un caractère luxe
alors un autre emprunt à la garde-robe
masculine que Gabriel Chanel va faire si
le tweed ce qu'elle aime c'est le côté
très irrégulier de ce fil et ce qui ne
te faisait pas du tout en France à
l'époque on voit que ce tweed qui semble
très simple au premier abord en fait si
on le regarde de plus près est un tweed
finalement assez sophistiqué voilà on
retrouve même un jeu presque de carreaux
dans ce tweed le tissage est extrêmement
complexe
on a un autre exemple de tweed celui-ci
date de 1963 c'est même probablement
l'archétype presque du tailleur Chanel
tel qu'il est gravé dans l'imaginaire
collectif c'est un tailleur avec une
Gans ici extrêmement graphique
ce détail de poche voilà un graphisme
très très épuré et en même temps c'est
un vêtement extrêmement confortable ce
tailleur est conçu pour une femme qui
bouge
Chanel a
contribué toute sa vie à éviter que la
femme ne soit entravée par le vêtement
et la conception du tailleur la
conception même qu'elle avait de la mode
en général était de la libérer des
carcans qu'ils soient psychologiques ou
qui soit physique voilà donc elle s'est
ingénée par tous les moyens à libérer la
femme
depuis son arrivée chez Chanel en 1983
Karl Lagerfeld est resté fidèle à la
grammaire de la maison
[Musique]
il en est une ici
cette robe en fait est en deux parties
un body en partie haute et cette jupe
couverte de Camélia en partie basse et
si vous remarquez bien vous allez voir
que les camélias
sont de taille croissantes c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont fermés en bouton tout en
haut et au fur et à mesure s'ouvre et
sont de plus en plus larges et cette
robe est couverte de 2500 camélias
or le camélia c'était la fleur fétiche
de Gabriel Chanel
ce sont les ateliers Lemarié qui ont
réalisé cette robe plus de 700 heures de
travail le plus Massy est aussi un
fleuriste hors pair et grâce à ses deux
savoir-faire le styliste de Chanel a pu
concevoir des pièces exceptionnelles
[Musique]
cette robe est exceptionnelle parce
qu'elle allie les deux savoir-faire de
la maison le marié à savoir le travail
des fleurs
des camélias et puis tous ces rinceaux
ici qui sont des rinceaux en plumes donc
on a cette double technique que l'on
retrouve ici sur cette robe
aujourd'hui comme il y a plus d'un
siècles chez le marié la fabrication des
fleurs suite un savoir-faire ancien et
artisanal première étape avec Mathieu la
prêteur de tissus tout simplement de la
soie la doublure en fait de veste
[Musique]
on dit on fait crier la matière
une fois bien étirée le tissu est alors
enduit d'un après à base de gélatine
alimentaire
l'après est bien chaud moi quand j'ai
appris à faire les après on m'a dit tant
que tu ne brûles pas c'est que c'est pas
c'est chaud
[Applaudissements]
et voilà après deux heures exactement
nous on retrouve un produit prêt à
l'emploi
prête à l'emploi et rigide
des pétales y sont alors découpés au
millimètre près grâce à ses moules
emporte-pièces très anciens certains ont
plus d'un siècle
reste alors à les bouler
faut que ça soit légèrement humide ouais
plus pratique pour pour gauguer pour que
ça prenne la forme donc ça c'est les
moyens qui est le deuxième rang autour
du cœur
[Musique]
ça tient avec un fil on monte avec un
fil et un peu de colle
[Musique]
et on assemble 20 minutes suffisent à
une fleuriste expérimentée pour bouler
et monter une fleur de camélia en soie
dans l'atelier d'à côté une dizaine de
fleuristes très concentrés finissent
d'assembler des centaines de pétales sur
une robe Chanel prévue pour défiler dans
trois jours donc là vous voyez un modèle
qui normalement devrait être livré
demain on est en phase terminale et on
espère bien être le finalisé comme il se
doit on a travaillé des matières
classiques comme la soie comme la
dentelle comme le lamé qui est un tissu
qui scintille mais aussi des matières
beaucoup plus modernes que des
dérodoïdes des matières plastiques qui
donnent un effet beaucoup plus moderne
ou peut-être au modèle
donc là elles sont en train de toute
coudes les fleurs une à une
pour demain voilà sachant qu'on a comme
toujours pas eu énormément de temps pour
faire l'ensemble du modèle une fois
terminée broderie et fleurs sont livrés
dans les ateliers de couture ou pour les
couturières commencent la course contre
la montre
nous sommes toujours dans les ateliers
de la maison Chanel et cette fois-ci en
compagnie de madame Cécile en Cécile
vous permet que j'appelle tout
simplement tout simplement Cécile je
préfère combien de robes vous réalisez
lors d'une collection haute couture
alors au sein de l'atelier nous
réalisons en général une vingtaine de
modèles une vingtaine de passages pour
combien de robes dans une collection
cette année on a fait 71 passages voilà
vous êtes surprise à chaque fois par les
nouvelles créations à chaque fournit
surprise parce que ce sont des matières
différentes parce que ce sont des
recherches différentes je vous dis c'est
toujours pareil c'est jamais pareil
c'est ça qui est formidable dans ce
métier là on mélange du tweed vous
m'arrêtez si je me trompe avec des
broderies moi je trouve ça d'une
modernité incroyable modernité mais
vraiment en plus c'est un trois pièces
c'est vous avez la robe la petite robe
bustine vous avez là bas le petit top et
le pantalon donc c'est l'assemblage des
trois et vous pouvez tout dissocier je
trouve ça génial comme idée qu'est-ce
qui est le plus difficile à faire dans
une robe à réaliser
tout est difficile tout demande beaucoup
du départ de la toile jusqu'à la
réalisation alors j'imagine que ça doit
être une course contre le temps non
avant le jour J du défilé pas du tout
si si bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr parce
qu'il y a la date butoir qui est là et
c'est c'est un peu comme une comme une
préparation de spectacle en fait c'est
il y a un stress qui monte et
comme avoir un spectacle mais c'est un
bon stress le temps est vraiment la clé
de tout que ce soit ici dans vos
ateliers ou dans les ateliers des autres
grandes maisons comme chez Christian
Dior nous avons eu la chance d'aller
dans l'atelier tailleur 2 jours avant un
défilé à leur croyez moi la pression
monte et vous allez voir sous vos yeux
la réalisation d'un tailleur pantalon
brodé avec de magnifiques broderies de
la maison Vermont
[Musique]
chez Dior nous retrouvons Nadège la
seconde de l'atelier tailleur elle est
en train de se battre avec des manches
du tailleur dont les broderies ont été
réalisées par la maison Vermont comme la
manche elle est étroite il faut que je
rentre tout à l'intérieur pour pouvoir
retourner
j'ai déjà du mal à passer la main
ensuite faut que j'attrape mon bas de
manche
faut que j'attrape le plastique en même
temps
et le plastique protège à évitera les au
broderies de
striper entre elles à l'intérieur il y a
pas d'autres moyens pour aller piquer la
machine que de retourner à la Manche
voilà je vais aller piquer la machine
maintenant
pour le moment la Manche est cousue
parce que l'on appelle des points de
bâti des points provisoirs que Nadège
remplace par une couture délicate et
définitive il faut tout son savoir-faire
pour y arriver
quoi que les fils de la broderie
s'accrochent
[Musique]
sa facilite pas le travail c'est sûr que
quand c'est les choses sont brodées
on met plus de temps en général pour
pour travailler donc voilà mais bon
c'est tellement le rendu est tellement
plus joli aussi
[Musique]
c'est un peu délicat parce que j'ai les
broderies des deux côtés il faut pas que
je les abîme en repassant mais on ouvre
les coutures on met en forme la Manche
et comme ça on peut la finir après
dans les ateliers de haute couture les
savoir-faire comme les traditions ont
traversé les siècles c'est vrai que on
est un peu superstitieux dans le métier
quand on renverse une boîte d'épingles
si elle est complètement retournée et
complètement de vie de d'épingle ça veut
dire qu'on va avoir beaucoup de travail
donc il faut qu'on jette des épingles
par dessus son épaule trois fois de
suite pour conjurer le sort
quand on a un nœud au centimètre ça veut
dire aussi beaucoup beaucoup de travail
donc il faut défaire le noeud avec une
seule main enfin c'est des choses
c'est rigolo en général les jeunes
filles quand il y a une robe de mariée
de fête celle qui veulent se marier ou
trouver un chéri elle met un cheveu dans
la robe de mariée de la cliente il faut
pas le dire
angélique ça t'est arrivé de mettre à
cheveux toi dans une robe de mariée
je suis mariée alors je ne sais pas si
ça a vraiment marché aussi c'est le
destin
mais je pense qu'on l'a tout fait donc
là regarde on se raccorde ici
on se raccorde aussi
là c'est bien je suis bien sur mes cran
regardez derrière
sur la toile la blouse du tailleur
commence par magie à prendre forme reste
maintenant à coudre tous les éléments
entre eux
tout est bien aligné apparemment
c'est couturières fleurons de la haute
couture française sous les héritières
des petites mains qui ont fait de Paris
à la fin du 19e siècle la capitale de
l'élégance
les maisons les collections et même les
défilés l'organisation de la haute
couture telle que nous la connaissons
aujourd'hui est né à cette époque-là au
Second Empire du monde entier les plus
riches se précipitaient dans la ville
lumière pour s'amuser sortir se montrer
et acheter leur nouvelle garde-robe car
les modistes parisiennes sont réputés
les meilleures couturières au monde
mais les délais sont très longs et les
artisans débordés alors un anglais
installé à Paris et homme d'affaires
avisé un certain Frédéric works profite
de l'opportunité
il a l'idée de faire des collections
c'est à dire des prototypes qu'il va
présenter à la clientèle sous la forme
de défilé chaque femme va pouvoir avoir
la robe de son choix dans les plus brefs
délais la clientèle lui est acquise
puisqu'il est ami de la princesse de
maternité qui va l'introduire à la cour
et à partir de là il va régenter le
monde de la mode et c'est un homme qui
prend le pouvoir sur la mode ces modèles
vont être vendus de manière extrêmement
rapide et pas des prix exorbitants il va
se considérer comme un artiste donc il
va signer ses robes il va poser une
griffe et voilà c'est la haute couture
est née
chez Dior à la veille du jour J le
stress est monté d'un cran
pour le studio l'équipe des stylistes
c'est l'heure des fittings une
répétition générale des passages avec
tous les mannequins
la tension et palpable dans un
chuchotement ou un regard un vêtement
peut être refusé ou modifié un mannequin
remercié
c'est aussi le moment où les stylistes
accessoirisent la silhouette
car de la tête aux pieds chaque détail
compte
même les chaussures doivent être à la
hauteur du vêtement magnifié par le
mannequin
[Musique]
entre la maison Massaro et la haute
couture c'est déjà une longue histoire
depuis 1894 le bottier parisien a
travaillé pour les plus grands ce qui
apparaît lime et surtout Chanel en 1957
le boîtier crée les fameux chaussures
bicolor beiges et noir pour Gabriel
Chanel un succès planétaire phénoménal
ici ce n'est que du fait main du sur
mesure de grand luxe
cette année encore pour ses collections
Karl Lagerfeld est resté fidèle à cet
atelier pour son savoir-faire et sa
capacité d'adaptation
Karl Lagerfeld a demandé une cuissarde
d'ailleurs nous avons ici son dessin
vous voyez qu'on a exprimé le talon qui
n'est pas très haut et ensuite on a le
bout du pied le bout du pied qui est
donc de forme carrée et un carré très
marqué ici
on a le premier prototype
qui a été donc soumis à kargar Feld on
voit ici le bout carré qui est un bout
carré très fin et on voit la hauteur de
la cuissarde mais la plus grosse
difficulté a été la mise en place du
plissé
le premier proto de plissée que l'on a
c'est celui-ci on l'a fait sur une base
basse alors là ça a été négatif puisque
le plisser et est trop mécanique la
volonté de Karl Lagerfel c'est d'avoir
un drapé quelque chose de flottant et de
naturel ensuite entendre
on tombe sur un autre essayage on a des
c'est un petit peu décoller mais enfin
je vous montre à peu près ce que ça peut
donner donc là on retrouve le bout de la
forme le bout du pied et ici vous avez
un drapé qui ici tombe naturellement pas
égal un peu un peu comme il vient et là
on a fixé une idée qui est parfaite il
aura donc fallu trois essayages pour
enfin répondre aux exigences du styliste
notre compétence c'est de s'adapter à la
demande et parfois d'aller dans des
terrains que l'on ne connaît pas et
d'arriver à le concrétiser et à en faire
quelque chose qu'on puisse se reproduire
dans des temps très limités et là c'est
là que qu'intervient le savoir-faire de
Jacques puisque une fois que je lui
donne le la
ensuite il avance il trouve des
solutions et ici la solution pour
maintenir le drapé avant de coudre c'est
cet ouvrier chevronné qui l'a trouvé une
astuce toute simple encore fallait-il y
penser
[Musique]
tu vas trouver ce système donc fixer à
l'aide d'un scotch de centre et sans
pour autant être obligé de le fixer
définitivement ses succins mais ça ça
lui a permis de produire ce drapé qui
était voulu pour la collection
[Musique]
une fois la cuissard de cousue le drapé
est définitivement maintenu
reste à enlever avec précaution le ruban
adhésif pour éviter d'abîmer la peau
rose poudrée
c'est alors au bottier monteur de
prendre le relais
et en fait moi je passe ça sur la forme
tous les éléments de la chaussure sont
fabriqués à la main ici
mais le travail à la main permet de
faire des choses que on peut pas faire
avec des machines la finesse les
dessins de semelles de chaussures
la machine elle permet pas elle permet
pas tout quoi
j'ai l'impression de faire un métier
d'art quelque part on est quand même des
fois on est des créateurs de rêve parce
qu'il y a des gens qui arrivent avec des
projets fous et on arrive à leur donner
satisfaction
c'est cuits
à la robe de mariée de la collection
Chanel sont prêtes à être livrées rue
Cambon
[Musique]
et justement rue Cambon chez Chanel à
trois jours du défilé la fabrication de
la collection automne-hiver touche à sa
fin sauf peut-être pour Madame Josette
première de l'atelier tailleur qui
commence à s'inquiéter pour la robe de
mariée que Karl Lagerfeld dev veut voir
le soir même
[Musique]
ça c'est fini donc ce soir ce soir car
Laura au moins le pantalon avec le
bustier monté et on va faire nos effets
avec la toile puisqu'on n'a pas on n'a
pas le reste de la robe donc on va faire
l'effet avec ça ça c'est la veste avec
la traîne
qui sera
rebrodé de plumes
tout en dentelle aussi et on a le
beaucoup de
on a le col de plumes qui sera remis là
comme ça normalement
alors là je vous mets comme ça juste
comme ça voilà
jusqu'en bas des manches qu'est-ce qui
vous reste à faire là presque tout
pas encore de manteau ni de traine mais
le bustier lui vient d'arriver elles
vont enfin pouvoir le monter
là elle bâtit elle bâtit et on va
pouvoir se remettre au mannequin voir si
j'ai bien la bonne image comme sur le
croquis que Carl veut pour le cintrage
voir si le fait d'avoir été molletonné
ça a pas perdu en largeur voir s'il faut
pas qu'on redonne
et après ben toute manière il faudra que
ce soit piqué pour ce soir voilà
avant de piquer c'est-à-dire coudre
définitivement le bustier mieux vaut
s'assurer que tout va bien sur le
mannequin
ce petit bustier intérieur sert de
fondation pour tenir l'autre qui est
dessus la couture c'est un peu de
l'architecture quand vous avez pas de
fondation les maisons tiennent pas là
c'est pareil quand il y a pas de bustier
la robe ne tient pas
pour l'instant on va se regarder comme
ça
[Musique]
le mannequin il est un peu faible je
pense la fille elle est un petit peu
plus forte non ça va ça se met bien il y
a pas de souci on va va falloir dégarnir
un petit peu dans les coutures pour pas
que ça fasse trop épais parce que sinon
ça va pas être très fin mais ça va je
vais regarder dans la glace pour le
centrage si on est en fait car vous
voulez que ce soit faut que ce soit
cintré mais pas trop faut qu'on ait le
bon gage là où il faut non ça va être
joli c'est les plumes quand c'est plus
en fait là c'est ça là c'est pas brodé
du tout et là il y avait pas de voiture
ça sera tout comme ça
là c'est avant après
la robe sera prête à ton elle aura
nécessité plus de 1200 heures de travail
et plus de 12 500 plumes
[Musique]
chez ce qui apparaît lit place Vendôme
c'est aussi la course contre la montre
le styliste Bertrand Guyon est en plein
essayage
c'est la troisième collection qu'il crée
pour la maison
cette fois il a réinterprété la
collection phare d'Alsace qui apparaît
le lit la collection cirque
80 ans après les techniques sauvegardées
et les savoir-faire exceptionnels
permettent au styliste de rester fidèle
à la grammaire de la maison ce qui
apparaît lit tout en la réinventant
par exemple cette robe
qui est une robe brodée
un tout petit peu
d'animaux
c'est très très lourd là vous avez
l'éléphant qui est sur sur sa balle le
zèbre les petits papillons ça aussi
c'est très Scapini les papillons
toujours la petite touche de
constellation il y a aussi
des petits singes ça c'est une broderie
tout à fait sublime
aucun de ces éléments n'appartient aux
archives
de le sage ce sont des
des dessins que nous réalisons ici dans
l'esprit on est en évoquant et en
restant 6
fidèle à l'esprit de la maison mais je
ne voulais pas que ce soit copier
dans cette collection le styliste grâce
à la maison le sage c'est même permis de
réinterpréter la fameuse cape Phébus
[Musique]
ce n'est pas du tout le même échantillon
ça c'est un travail très contemporain
qui a un côté un peu aussi au sensoir et
un côté christique par dans cette veste
j'aime beaucoup
pour cette collection cirque j'avais
envie juste d'ajouter une petite touche
de cubisme comme ça c'est pas non plus
une citation à Picasso mais je trouvais
que c'était assez beau d'avoir d'avoir
des bustier graphiques comme ça avec des
patchs de matière qui évoque un Picasso
en reprenant le shopping parce qu'à
Paris évidemment et puis certains
éléments de de ce qui constitue la robe
en son entier bon là évidemment elle est
protégée parce que c'est très fragile
mais ça c'est justement la jupe qui ira
avec le petit bustier c'est un travail
assez incroyable
ce sont des
petites franches de cellophane qui sont
cousues sur une base de tulle mais on le
voit chaque bande à sa couleur et cosu
sur un tulle pour former cette espèce de
de Rainbow
et en fait ce qui est amusant c'est que
dans les archives de la maison
j'ai retrouvé ce modèle qui doit tâter
de 35 36 on voit une robe qui est qui
était en lamée
et qui reprend
cette même idée de
d'arc-en-ciel
c'est je dirais une coïncidence parce
que là pour le coup
très très honnêtement je n'avais pas
j'avais pas vu
mais là on est complètement dans le
dans l'univers de ce qui est Paris
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour dans les ateliers
de la maison Chanel en compagnie de
madame Cécile alors Cécile vous me le
disiez tout à l'heure c'est 14 ans que
vous travaillez dans cette prestigieuse
maison comment êtes-vous devenu première
d'atelier faut apprendre le métier très
jeune on démarre on est apprenti c'est
tout un système de c'est un peu comme du
compagnonnage en fait l'apprenti elle
est associée avec une couturière qui lui
apprend le métier de jour en jour de
mois en mois d'année en année comme ça
on gravit les échelons et après on passe
seconde d'atelier et
parfois il y a une place qui se libère
et on est choisie comme première
d'atelier et il faut se lancer aussi
quelles sont les qualités requises pour
entrer dans une grande maison comme la
vôtre la patience la passion
cette passion qui vous la transmise vous
ma mère elle est écoutée hier elle aussi
elle était couturière aussi oui et quand
on posait la question quand j'étais plus
jeune tu veux faire comme ta mère ah non
pas du tout la transmission c'est
vraiment important c'est très important
c'est un patrimoine c'est un vrai
patrimoine qu'on a en France de
fabriquer encore ici à Paris de la vraie
haute couture ça c'est une grande chance
et de transmettre ce métier ces métiers
de passion donc automatiquement on a
envie de les transmettre pas que ça se
perde j'imagine que la pression monte
petit à petit lorsque le jour J du du
défilé arrive j'ai les mains moites
avant de défiler j'ai le trac je suis je
sais pas quelle heure il est j'ai
vraiment j'ai les yeux qui sont partout
c'est on va vous retrouver justement
quelques minutes avant le défiler et on
va aller côté coulisse
[Musique]
pour la maison Chanel le grand jour est
arrivé dans ce vestiaire féerique 71
modèles qui représente des milliers
d'heures de travail alors à quelques
minutes du défilé la tension monte
Cécile notre première d'atelier ne tient
pas en place et fais le tour de ses
trésors
[Musique]
comme ça
et tu les positionnes comme ça comme ça
ok voilà d'accord
[Musique]
oui je sais mais je préfère
dernier petit conseil aux habilleuses
car cécile va bientôt devoir leur
laisser ses bébés
[Musique]
c'est pour moi surtout
bonjour
[Musique]
après les défilés les applaudissements
et les aura la plupart de ces modèles
d'exception ira rejoindre les trésors du
patrimoine de la maison c'est le cachet
Chanel comme chez toutes les autres
maisons de haute couture et notamment
chez Christian Dior l'autre grande
maison
[Musique]
dans son showroom avenue Montaigne Dior
expose ses looks
de la toute première collection de 1947
à 40 ans alors inconnu du grand public
Christian Dior au sortir de la guerre
propose aux femmes une nouvelle ligne la
ligne corolle
ces deux vêtements représentent
complètement la révolution de la
première collection de Monsieur Dior au
printemps été 47 ce sont deux vêtements
de la ligne corolle et bien sûr le
fameux tailleur emblématique le tailleur
bar les saints haut placés la taille
très très fine et les hanches accentuées
pour avoir un contraste très important
entre une taille très très fine et des
hanches plus larges monsieur derdier
qu'il voulait rendre des femmes plus
belles et plus heureuses
le style New Look était né selon la
fameuse expression d'une journaliste de
mode américaine séduite par la
collection
souvent c'est aperçu qu'en fait cette
collection des modèles toutes les autres
et c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment une
vraie révolution
tout à coup en février 47 Dior restaure
le goût du luxe le goût de l'opulence le
goût de la féminité dans une période qui
était encore marquée par la pénurie par
la pénurie textile notamment donc il
relance le goût du rêve en fait et les
femmes vont adorer vont rêver de ça il
relance le goût du rêve mais il relance
aussi un certain formalisme aussi bien
pour le corps qui est à nouveau corseté
dans dans des vêtements qui sont lourds
qui sont extrêmement armaturés qui sont
contraignants pour le corps et une mode
aussi qui est contraignante dans la
mesure où pour chaque circonstance de la
journée il va trouver une toilette
appropriée et notamment la fameuse robe
de cocktail puisque il va faire de cette
robe de cocktail un des éléments
emblématiques de sa production
la robe de cocktail mais aussi la robe
de bal
la robe Junon de la collection 1949 en
est le meilleur exemple un des trésors
les plus précieux du patrimoine Dior
les pétales sont constitués d'une bande
de paillettes de coloris plus foncées
pour organiser le tour du pétale de cinq
couleurs différentes dans les temps de
bleu et de verre et puis vers
l'intérieur il y a des petites cuvettes
en fait c'est des paillettes plus
creusées qui sont irisés et qui donnent
toute la lumière sur la robe et qui
magnifique cette robe du soir
il y avait une robe de balle à choisir
pour évoquer monsieur Dior ça serait
cette robe cette robe Junon qui qui fait
rêver
encore maintenant dans les trois musées
dans lesquels elle se trouve également
Christian Dior savait aussi utiliser
avec élégance le savoir-faire des
pisseurs le plisser un incontournable de
la maison Dior que ses successeurs de
1957 à nos jours réinvente sans cesse et
là c'est un très beau plissé qui est
présent dans la collection de la haute
couture prête ont été 2015 un plissé
réalisé par la société l'oignon en fait
cette jupe est construite avec des des
panneaux de hauteurs différentes pour
retrouver ensuite ce volume et c'est pas
nos son brodés de de rubans parfois ils
sont superposés les uns aux autres donc
il y a déjà un vrai premier travail ici
sublime et ensuite ces différents
panneaux sont plissés mais à des
différentes en implicé accordéon pour
avoir ce volume qui qui graduellement
s'ouvre de plus en plus et donner cette
belle ouverture corolle très typique des
robes Dior
[Musique]
c'est ici dans l'atelier l'oignon que
les maisons de haute couture font encore
réalisées leur pisser à deux ou à quatre
mains selon un savoir-faire séculaire un
atelier de légende qui depuis 1850 a su
créer plus de 3000 plissés différents
Raphaël jeune contremaître prépare l'un
des plissées les plus classiques le
plissé accordéon donc là je vais placer
un panneau tulle préalablement repassé
pour qu'il y ait plus aucune trace de
pliure
le panneau de tissu est alors inséré
entre deux cartons mis l'un sur l'autre
appelé un métier
est-ce que tu peux m'aider à fermer s'il
te plaît
donc là on va remettre l'épaisseur de
carton du dessus strictement
correspondante au pli du métier du
dessous quand on referme moi je trouve
ça magique parce que je me dis mon Dieu
si la mousseline a bougé à l'intérieur
la surprise on l'a en démoulant le
lendemain chaque plie est alors réalisé
un an un savoir-faire d'excellence à
l'aveugle ou presque il y a un petit
claquement à chaque fois que je fais un
pli
[Musique]
c'est le poids qui se lève et des
redescend si jamais il y a un problème
je vais le bruit va pas être le même
parce qu'il y aura une sur épaisseur par
exemple
et je vais sentir ne serait-ce que bruit
et à la main je vais sentir une sur
épaisseur là si le tissu est légèrement
déformé ce qui paraît sur des tissus
teint ou sur des mousselines très
fragiles je peux à l'oeil et avec le
doigt et avec le souffle je peux venir
placer pour compenser ça va être la
tension du métier ça va être au moment
de clisser on peut on peut faire avec
les aléas de la matière soit parce que
au niveau de la teinture ça a été
déformé soit parce que c'est très
fragile ce qu'une machine ne peut pas
faire je vais venir rouler pour être de
faire en sorte d'être parallèle à chaque
prix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'arrive au dernier pli je suis pas mal
le cylindre est alors placé dans cette
étude à 85 degrés pendant une heure
le temps de séchage lui est beaucoup
plus long 6 heures minimum
loin de tomber en désuétude le plisser
évolue aujourd'hui les créateurs
demandent de plus en plus de plisser
fantaisies sur des matières très
différentes comme le cuir par exemple
mis à rude épreuve les métiers en carton
s'abîment rapidement et l'atelier doit
régulièrement les renouveler un
savoir-faire indispensable c'est celui
de Marion toute la journée elle
construit ses origamis géants pour lui
faciliter la tâche aujourd'hui un
drainage numérique la guide mais le
reste est fait main plie par pli selon
votre sens du pli donc vous voyez que
vous avez un pli cru parce qu'on appelle
un valet et un pli en montagne vous
allez plier dans le bon sens
qu'on a trépillé en fonction des
montagnes et des vallées chaque pli
et maintenant on essaye de le mettre en
forme si vous inversez un pli vallée
avec imprimontagne ce qui fait que tout
votre métier après va être inversé vous
avez plus qu'à recommencer
ce que je préfère faire dans mon métier
c'est créer de nouveaux métiers
généralement on a des maisons qui nous
demandent des choses qu'on a pas
forcément dans nos archives malgré le
grand nombre de métiers que l'on a par
exemple le dernier métier que j'ai fait
c'était pour la dernière collection de
Chanel
c'était même deux métiers
qui ont le même motif mais avec des
mesures différentes
faites ce sont les croisillons
ça se croise là vous l'avez en plus
grand
vous le voyez
se croisent donc c'est une recherche en
fait de mesure et de géométrie de sorte
à ce que chaque pli arrive au bon
endroit
sans que ça se croise et que ça puisse
bien se plier
il lui a fallu plus d'un mois pour
réaliser ce nouveau métier
poussez les métiers d'art aller toujours
plus loin pour innover dans l'art de
vetyre être le premier visionnaire à
lancer les nouvelles tendances de la
mode de demain c'est ce que recherche
chaque maison de haute couture qui
rivalise de créativité
[Musique]
chez Dior le créateur Ralph Simons a
créé cette robe en 2014
voguant avec audace sur le thème de la
récup version haute couture
au hausse de sacrilège peut-être
effectivement puisque on ose associer un
organza de satin a à de la gomme qui est
matière beaucoup moins noble ça c'est
une première chose et puis deuxième
chose c'est que les éléments évidés on
nous on les récupère entre guillemets
pour les utiliser comme éléments de
broderie d'une part pour le haut de la
robe et également aussi pour la partie
fourreau de la jupe et donc ça donne
maintenant une vraie robe tout à fait
technique très très novatrice et
complètement différent d'une robe qui au
départ était en tout vêtements en
organza de satin
chez scaparelli pour la collection était
2016 sur le thème du dîner le créateur
Bertrand Guyon lui est allé chercher un
artisanat d'art plutôt insolite dans la
haute couture
l'idée c'était d'avoir des porcelines
qui soient vraiment complètement
intégrés au travail
et chaque pièce
est réalisée avec les codes de la maison
on est parti sur des recherches qui sont
réalisées un peu avec ce que nous avons
là en l'occurrence chaque plaque de
porcelaine a été travaillée avec un
carton pour voir si ça fonctionnait le
carton est troué et puis crocheter
d'une manière assez rapide juste pour
voir si au fond l'idée pouvait être
intéressantes et à partir de là
on est parti sur des échantillons
de porcelaine que nous avons fait faire
chaque petite plaque en elle-même est un
petit bijou vraiment ravissant là par
exemple ici au tout début il y avait des
petites fleurs un peu un peu naïf c'est
à dire qu'en fait elle était partie
vraiment de cette photocopie de
d'assiettes collées sur un carton mais
au final c'était un petit peu voilà
c'était pas forcément très intéressant
et progressivement on est venu très
naturellement à retraduire les codes de
la maison ce qui était beaucoup plus
identitaire par rapport à la maison ce
qui apparaît
et sur cette veste qui est réalisée avec
des torchons anciens
et brodés de Potigny
on voit les petits boutons qui racontent
un peu l'histoire de l'oeuf avec l'oeuf
qui devient le fêlé puis cassé et
ensuite qui devient un petit œuf sur le
plat
c'est à ça une dans la Drôme très loin
de l'ambiance feutrée des salons de
haute couture que Bertrand Guyon a
trouvé une porcelaine hier artisandard
depuis près de 40 ans Hélène latoumessie
est connue pour son savoir-faire la
finesse et la délicatesse de ces pièces
uniques je pense qu'ils m'ont choisi
parce que je suis dans le détail moi je
travaille beaucoup le détail et la haute
couture c'est ça c'est vraiment
travailler le détail
il y a pas cette histoire d'être
rentable pas du tout dans la haute
couture et moi aussi j'ai ça moi je m'en
fiche d'être rentable ou pas je fais ce
que j'ai envie
au mieux au mieux de ce qui m'intéresse
et du coup on s'est rencontré par là
c'est la première fois qu'elle aime
travaillait pour la haute couture et
malgré son savoir-faire exceptionnel
cela n'a pas toujours été simple de
s'adapter aux exigences
les œufs c'est ce qui a été le plus dur
à mettre au point en fait si je les cuis
directement sur la plaque d'enfournement
ça colle comme là donc je suis obligée
de les cuire suspendu mais comme c'est
de la haute température moi je suis à
1300 degrés il y a ça fond ça joue
beaucoup et donc les mailles c'est à
peine un peu épais faisait cette petite
boule là qui est vraiment pas belle dans
la forme d'un œuf
donc du coup pour pas avoir ça j'ai dû
émailler très très fin mais en émaillant
trop fin
l'or ne peut pas être brillant leur
prend à la recuisson prend le brillant
du support donc si mon émail est trop
fin il devient un peu mat lors du coup
ne reste mat et donc cela aussi ont été
refusés donc j'ai fait plein plein plein
plein de petit œuf celui-là il réussit
quand j'ai ça j'étais bien contente
pour arriver à cet équilibre parfait
hélène a dû jeter 80% de sa production
c'est le tournage à la mode en fait vous
imaginez bien cette petite oeuf je peux
pas le faire directement
sur ma girl sur ce plateau
[Musique]
donc je suis obligé de le faire
sur une mode de terre
[Musique]
donc l'air est enfermé dedans à partir
de là je peux trouver ma forme
la porcelaine c'est une très très belle
matière et qui a une référence
historique je pense que ils sont allés
chercher aussi ça à travers mon travail
après jour
dans 24 heures ce petit œuf sera prêt à
être dégourdi c'est à dire cuit dans un
four à 980 degrés pour ensuite être
émaillé
donc comme c'était toute petite pièce
je mets mon émail dans un pot
après les maillages les pièces sont
cuites à nouveau à 1300 degrés un
artisanat d'art ancestral dont les
contraintes ne sont pas toujours faciles
à concilier avec celle de la haute
couture c'est vrai que nous en céramique
on a on a un délai d'au moins une
semaine à 10 jours quoi c'est pas il y a
un cycle avec la terre alors que en
Haute Couture ils sont tout le temps de
ce que j'ai vu ils sont tout le temps à
la bourre pour répondre du tac au tac
comme ça et avec ce décalage là oui
direction le four à gaz
les créateurs de haute couture ont
toujours été à la recherche de nouvelles
matières pour de nouveaux rendus
aujourd'hui les nouvelles technologies
leur permettent d'innover encore
davantage
en 2014 dans sa collection hommage à
l'architecte Le Corbusier Karl Lagerfeld
pour la maison Chanel est allé plus loin
dans cette démarche jusqu'à
l'inimaginable des broderies en béton
c'est carrément gonflé enfin vraiment
mettre du du béton dans la haute couture
ça semble tellement improbable et
pourtant voilà il l'a fait ça marche
très bien et on a ici une robe
parfaitement glamour donc c'était tous
c'était possible et une fois de plus je
crois que le parallèle avec la démarche
de Gabriel Chanel qui elle-même en 1913
va utiliser des matériaux dit pauvres à
l'époque c'est à dire des matériaux
qu'on ne considérait pas comme des
matériaux nobles
et bien quelque part c'est un petit peu
peut-être la même démarche et voilà plus
plus de 100 ans c'est par ces deux
démarches et pourtant elles ont vraiment
un point commun ça c'est certain
[Musique]
la haute couture et la vitrine des
métiers d'art français elle permet aux
artisans de développer et de conserver
leur savoir-faire et au styliste de
pouvoir compter sur des techniques et
des maîtres d'art d'excellence envier et
admirer dans le monde entier
ensemble ces hommes et ces femmes ont su
sauvegarder plus d'un siècle de luxe
ensemble il crée aujourd'hui les trésors
et le patrimoine de la haute couture de
demain en s'inspirant de l'héritage
d'hier
[Musique]
comme vous venez de le voir la haute
couture française RA
Yonne et cela a priori ne devrait pas
changer tout cela c'est grâce au talent
de ces hommes et de ses femmes qui ont
un savoir-faire et une passion
absolument exceptionnelle pour ma part
j'espère vous avoir fait découvrir des
chefs-d'œuvre qui font notre fierté et
je vous retrouve très bientôt pour
découvrir de nouveaux trésors
[Musique]